hello ladies and gents today's video is
origin the spirits of past it's a sci-fi
romance movie released in 2006. the film
itself is very beautiful and quite
underrated if you ask me so without any
further ado let's jump right into it
origin spirits of the past is the story
of agito a young boy living in a
dystopian japan set 300 years in the
future this apocalypse was brought about
by extensive genetic engineering on
trees conducted a research facility on
earth's moons in order to produce trees
capable of growing in harsh arid
conditions the trees became conscious
and spread to earth in a fiery holocaust
wiping out most of modern civilization
and fragmenting the moon aguito's world
is covered mostly by the forest a huge
expanse of living trees ruled by the
tree-like druid which now inhabit the
earth and control the water supply of
both trees and humans agito and his
father as well as his friends kane and
minka live in neutral city a city carved
out of the ruined skyscrapers of an old
metropolis neutral city acts as both a
buffer and a bridge between the forest
and the militaristic nation of ragna
while the people of neutral city coexist
peacefully with the trees of the forest
the nation of ragnar aims to destroy the
forest in order to return the world to
the way it was before the mutant trees
invaded the movie starts with agito and
his friend kane racing each other to see
who can get to the waterhole at the
bottom of the city first by disturbing
the sanctity of the waterhole and
angering the druids the two boys are
separated and agito stumbles upon a
large machine with cryogenic pods
containing mostly dead bodies inside the
only active pod he finds tulla a young
girl who's been asleep for the past 300
years he revives her and right after
reviving her the forest drains all the
water to kill her argito helps her and
they reach a building bury deep down
called the stayfield control room tula
uses her rabban a portable personal
electronic device worn as a necklace
that can be used for communication and a
variety of other tasks to enter the
building with agito after they managed
to set out from the room agito shows her
the neutral city they live in and
invites her to live with him but she's
still confused about this strange
situation of the world she meets yonder
an enhanced woman like argitos and
kane's father acknowledging her as a
past world human she allows tula to live
in neutral city which made agito and his
friends happy yonder as the city
representative asked the forest to
release water but the forest refuses to
do so because of tulla the forest
angered by tulla's awakening since she's
carries a rabbun the forest fears that
she'll fall into the hands of shunok a
soldier of ragnar and also a person from
the past who's awakened from sleep and
that will use her rabban to locate
e-stock the environmental regrowth
defragmentation system a powerful weapon
with the ability to wipe out the forest
and restore human control over the world
schunak's the main villain of the film
and the best part about the film is that
the antagonist motives actually make
sense instead of making someone purely
evil schunk's character is multi-layered
the forest considers her the harbinger
of destruction for both mankind and the
forest ragna city announced a reward for
anyone who locates the person from the
past agito and kane got punished for
their adventure in the forest they got
tasked with extraction work in a ruined
building as a punishment on the other
hand minka was tasked with guiding tulla
around the city she took her to the main
market of the city where people from all
over the world gather to sell things in
exchange for water but because of the
water shortage water itself has become a
currency then she showed tulla her
working place which was a bar on their
way back home they filled buckets of
water for use tulla had a hard time
carrying a single bucket because of a
fragile physique while leaving minka
told her that she'll be the future wife
of agito she said so because aguito
seemed to be interested in tula
someone's trying to contact tulla by her
raban as it starts ringing suddenly then
agito notices her walking to the forest
and goes after her as it's dangerous
there he introduced his father to her
who was almost a tree with some
remaining human body agito's father told
her to accept this reality of humans if
she wants to live in this world argito
boasted about his father and other
people who built this city on their own
as a peaceful place for living shunak
eventually finds out about tula and
marches into neutral city with his army
to persuade her to join him the forest
sends a giant creature to stop the
meeting which schunak single-handedly
destroys revealing that he has been
enhanced he allowed himself to be
genetically altered by the forest in
order to become stronger by using the
power of the trees convinced that
finding e-stock is the only way to
restore the earth back to the world
which she once knew tula joined schunak
in his quest to spy aguito's plea not to
agito consults with his father the
founder of neutral city who as a result
of being enhanced and having overused
his powers has turned almost completely
into a tree with a few days left before
becoming a tree completely he encourages
aguito to save the forest from
shoenack's plan since destroying the
trees would mean the destruction of
mankind as well aguito journeys to the
forest minka decides to go with her as
she couldn't stop him minkah's father
stomps her telling her that it's agito's
decision and they should respect it
after entering the forest he submits
himself to the forest the forest grants
him powers and he awakens with a new
enhanced body with white silver hairs
agito rushes to ragnar where shunok took
tula by using his enhanced body he
reached the city within minutes and
destroyed the guarding machines with his
powerful fists shunak ordered his men to
attack him even the most powerful
weapons were useless against him the
army of ragnar uses sleeping gas on the
orders of shunok to capture him they
restrained him with big metal chains
upon regaining consciousness aguito sees
tulla he tries again to convince her but
she ignores his warnings she leaves
while telling him that it's for the best
of mankind schunak secretly orders his
men to kill agito he gathered all of his
strength and use the power of the forest
to break free from the chains he rushes
out and attacks the train with his
tree-like hand the army attacked him but
like always it was no use shunak moves
all the gunpowder to the back of the
train and releases that compartment of
the trade he then unleashes fire on the
leftover block causing it to blow off
now this particular sequence is quite
intense agito sustained some injuries
because of it and went mad with rage
yonder finds him and helps him regain
control of his body she told him to
control the enhanced powers by focusing
his consciousness on the seed implanted
within him by the forest after calming
down agito followed shunak and tula to
e-stock which turns out to be a huge
volcano converted into a mechanized
weapon
e-stock as it turns out was created by
tulla's father the doctor who'd begun
the genetic research on the trees as a
safeguard against the new species
schunk betrays the ragna army in
commandeers estoc revealing his true
intentions to use the weapon to clear
his guilt it so happens that schunak
worked on the original genetic
alteration experiments on the trees but
becoming impatient had tried to speed up
the alteration process leading to the
catastrophic invasion of the mutant
trees a holograph of dr sakul who's
tula's father appears after the
activation of estoc that explains
everything about the machine and the
destruction it can cause the doctor
ended the speech by giving the decision
of using e-stock to the people of
stayfield the ragnar army attacked the
moving mounted e-stock with all their
weapons the mountain activates weapons
for counter-attacking to the demise of
the ragnar army the weapons were more
advanced and powerful the flames of war
reached the neutral city but kane's
father destroys the incoming meteors
with its enhanced powers when tulla
learns that schunak intends to activate
e-stock on neutral city destroying it
completely in the process she has a
change of heart tries to stop shunak
from activating e-stock but is quickly
overwhelmed agito finds them and has a
showdown with schunak to save tulla he
lets his enhancement take over and he
transforms into a tree essentially
killing himself and shoenok in the
process tula deactivates estoc while
looking at the hologram of her father
and the weapon and the weapon begins to
self-destruct however tula refuses to
leave without aagito having developed
strong feelings for him although
aguito's body has been absorbed by the
tree his consciousness is intact on
another plane and there the forest
reveals to him the truth about the
relationship between itself and the
humans argito learns that the genetic
admixture that gives humans
extraordinary strength and eventually
turns them into trees is really a
two-way exchange it also changes the
forest causing trees to give birth to
new humans in giant fruits shunak having
become one with the forest finds peace
with himself and no longer intends to
fight agito the forest seeing the argito
can teach humanity that there's no need
for either hostility or separation
between themselves and the trees grants
him his human form back allowing him and
tula to escape before east stock erupts
into flames
having saved both the humans and the
forest agito brings peace between all
humans in the trees tulla finally lets
go of her past by throwing her rabbana
off a ledge down into the depths of the
forest and learning to live in harmony
with the trees at last so basically the
film actually has a deeper message
behind its plot it portrays the horrors
of climate change so that was it for
today's video we hope you enjoyed it
make sure to hit that like button and
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
for similar videos